.
IT'S TOO HOT, TOO SENSITIVE.
TOO MUCH AT STAKES.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON TONIGHT,
KEN.
AND HUNTER BIDEN MIGHT NOT BE
THE ONLY CONFLICT OF INTEREST
PROBLEM.
IN A NEW LETTER TO RON KLAIN
BEING RELEASED ON THIS SHOW
TONIGHT, THREE GOP CONGRESSMEN
ARE REQUESTING DOCUMENTS RELATED
TO ATTORNEY LEE LEWOLSKI.
HE WAS HIRED TO WORK WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL ON
SETTLEMENTS AND REGARDING THE
U.S. DRAW DOWN FROM AFGHANISTAN.
HE RESIGNED IN JANUARY.
THAT'S WHERE THINGS GET
INTERESTING, A MONTH LATER,
BIDEN ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
SPLITTING $3.5 BILLION IN ASSETS
FROM THE AFGHAN CENTRAL BANK
AMONG THE 9-11 VICTIMS.
THE ATTORNEY REPRESENTING THE
FAMILIES?
YOU GET IT, LEE WOLOSKY.
JOINING US NOW, ONE OF THE
COSIGNERS OF THE LETTER, OHIO
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN.
>> YOU LAID IT OUT, LAURA.
HE GETS HIRED IN SEPTEMBER,
LEAVES IN JANUARY.
DAYS AFTER HE LEAVES, WE FIND
OUT THAT HIS LAW FIRM, HE'S
REPRESENTING THE PLAINTIFFS THAT
GET THE WIND FALL BECAUSE JOE
BIDEN CHANGED THE PROCESS WITH
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
DIDN'T GO THROUGH THE NORMAL
FUND YOU GO THROUGH FOR FAMILIES
THAT HAVE BEEN HURT BY
TERRORISM.
SO THAT RAISES ALL KINDS OF
CONCERNS.
THEN YOU COUPLE THAT WITH WHAT
WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT THE HUNTER
BIDEN SITUATION.
THINGS THAT GET DONE THAT
BENEFIT THE FIRST FAMILY.
THAT'S OUR CONCERN AND WHY WE
SENT THE LETTER.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE LAWYERS IS
DEFENDING THAT HUGE AMOUNT OF
LEGAL FEES THEY'RE RESET TO
RECEIVE.
ANOTHER LAWYER DISMISSED THE
CRITICISM THAT THEIR POTENTIAL
WIND FALL IS UNFAIR.
20 YEARS AGO, EVERYBODY THOUGHT
WE WERE CRAZY WHEN WE FILED THIS
LAWSUIT.
WHEN YOU'RE A SUCCESS, YOU'RE
GREEDY LAWYERS, HE SAID.
YOUR RESPONSE.
LAWYERS DO GET A LOT OF MONEY,
CONGRESSMAN.
AS A FORMER PRACTICING ATTORNEY,
YOU KNOW, IF IT'S 800, TO $1,000
AN HOUR, I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
CHARGE OR HOW THEY CALCULATED
IT, IT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
>> THEY DO.
BUT THIS HAPPENED DAYS AFTER HE
LEAVES THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE HE
WAS WORKING ON MATTERS THAT
PERTAIN TO AFGHANISTAN.
HE LEAVES.
THE MONEY THAT COMES FROM
AFGHANISTAN GOES AROUND THE
NORMAL PROCESS IN TO A NEW FUND
THAT WILL BENEFIT THE VERY
CLIENT THAT HE'S REPRESENTING
JUST DAYS AFTER HE LEAVES THE
WHITE HOUSE.
SO AGAIN, THIS IS THE SAME WHITE
HOUSE THAT TOLD US ON SUNDAY,
OH, THERE'S NOTHING TO WORRY
ABOUT.
HUNTER BIDEN AND JOE BIDEN DID
NOTHING WRONG ACCORDING TO RON
KLAIN, THE SAME RON KLAIN THAT
YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT THAT WAS
GOING TO HUNTER BIDEN SAYING CAN
YOU GIVE US MONEY TO HELP THE
VICE PRESIDENT AND KEY IT LOW
KEY.
IT'S A CONCERN WHEN YOU HAVE
THIS HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME,
WE'RE LEARNING ALL KINDS OF
INFORMATION RELATIVE TO THE
FIRST FAMILY.
>> Laura: AS YOU HEARD JOE BIDEN
SAY OH, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
THEY HAVE TO ACT INDEPENDENTLY.
I'M NOT PUTTING ANY PRESSURE.
BUT THEN THEY MANAGE TO LEAK OUT
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WANTS MERRICK
GARLAND, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
TO ACT MORE LIKE A PROSECUTOR
AND LESS THAN A JUDGE.
THEY KNEW THAT WAS COMING OUT.
>> YEAH, THEY WANTED HIM TO GO
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THINK ABOUT HOW THIS HUNTER
BIDEN STORY CHANGED.
IT WASN'T HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP.
THEN IT WAS OH, IT'S HIS LAPTOP
BUT RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
THEN IT'S NOT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION BUT JOE BIDEN
WASN'T INVOLVED.
NOW THEY DID ANYTHING WRONG.
THAT IS AMAZING HOW THAT IS
EVOLVED OVER 18 MONTHS.
NO, THIS IS NOT TRUE TO NOW WE
HAVE "THE WASHINGTON POST" LAST
WEDNESDAY WRITE TWO STORIES.
TWO EIGHT-PAGE STORIES FOUR
MINUTES APART SAYING IT'S TRUE.
THE LAPTOP THE REAL, THE EYE
WITNESS IS REAL, THE E-MAILS ARE
REAL.
THE ONLY THING FAKE WAS THE NEWS
AND IT WAS JUST DAYS BEFORE THE
MOST IMPORTANT ELECTION WE HAD
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE
DENIED AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THE FACTS IN FRONT OF THEM.
WHEN THEY MAKE A DECISION ABOUT
WHO IS OUR COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
THAT'S WHY IN IS SO IMPORTANT.
THEN YOU COUPLE IT IT WITH THIS
STORY HOW THIS ONE LAWYER
BENEFITTED DAYS AFTER HE LEFT
THE WHITE HOUSE?
THAT IS WHY SO MANY AMERICANS
ARE SO FRUSTRATED BY WHAT THEY
SEE GOING ON IN TODAY'S WHITE
HOUSE AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: IT'S NICE "THE
WASHINGTON POST" SAYS IT'S TIME
FOR A RECKONING OVER THE HUNTER
BIDEN STORY.
BUT IT'S KIND OF LATE.